hey guys welcome back to brand-new hood
Eber Beck on for honor again and today
is Friday the Halloween event just
started yesterday and I wanted to give
you guys a guide on how to get the loot
the fastest we're gonna go for what that
is how to get it in as well as the
arcade effect later in the video since
that really it doesn't really need a
description what just in case you didn't
know let's get in with today's video so
first we need to go over what is
included this means the new outfit I
forgot the name but it's something with
the Sonata at the end the new ornament
the new Blood Moon effect and the new
weapon skins some of these I have and
some of these I don't for example I do
not have any of the new effect I've been
getting very unlucky with that recently
there's also the exclusive Arcade Mode
effect which like I said we will get
into later in the video but we need to
pick the right game mode this time I
found out that breach versus AI does
absolute wonders and that only is it a
decent source for XP in completing
orders you 99% of the time are going to
be getting loot especially stuff that's
event only I don't know if you guys
haven't gotten loot from breach but from
the games that I've been playing and I'm
playing a lot of breach I haven't
experienced this so first I'm just gonna
go with the fact that you get basically
loot every single game the only issue
that comes into play is that these bots
are almost always level 3 maybe a couple
level two sprinkled in there so I'm
going to give you guys some strategies
on what I use on attacking and defending
to make these matches go a little bit
quicker so first up is attacking
immediately go for the archer points and
try to cap them if not all of them or
even most of them you don't really have
to get the one that's all the way in the
back above the gate until you usually
get close enough because then it's just
a lot of wasted time you can get it if
you want it's totally up to you but
obviously since breach is a foreman mode
you can let your teammates do it or this
is even better if you're in a four-man
team you guys can designate roles one
person gets the RAM one person gets the
minions and then the other person gets
the capture points and all that stuff
like that just to make these games go
even quicker on top of that after the
archer points are done you definitely
want to be double speeding the RAM the
entire way if you don't know what that
means on the top right or where the RAM
is located you're going to be seeing a
couple arrows or a stop if there's a red
square that means that the RAM is
stopped there is no minions or here up
next to it if there is one if there is
either one minion or one hero next to
the RAM it'll be speeded at one speed
meaning it's just going half the speed
it should be
but if there is minion and a hero
together then it will be two speeds so
that it's going the fastest it can
possibly can so try to make sure that
you stay near the RAM and your minions
are alive and you kill the opposing
minions because if the opposing minions
group or another hero comes in it dumps
down the speed so it's not going to be -
it's gonna be one again and you always
want to be going double speed on the RAM
just that you can get this match over
with as quick as possible
on top of that when you're halfway
through in this section to the gate you
want to be checking the offering to see
if it spawns and then put it on the ramp
it's a lot I mean it's not a huge deal
if they do put it on the gate since it
doesn't really take too many hits it's
just one extra hit but it's a lot better
if you put it on the rim especially if
you're attacking so that you don't get
it destroyed and that's small case
scenario and then just repeat this step
for the inner gate as well and then once
you're at the commander usually the
whole team will rush them if you're
doing solo queue experience that's
almost all the time so there really
shouldn't be an issue on this phase just
do a bunch of buffs health boss for the
whole team most of the attacking games
go a little bit longer than the
defending since I will get into that in
a second most of my games you go from
ten to fifteen minutes my quickest a
breach game going about ten minutes and
thirty seconds that is my record for
that but most games can go around there
especially if you speed boost the RAM
and you could be done in very quick time
now for defending I personally want to
focus on kills as soon as it starts just
kill all the bots make sure that they
don't get the archer points and stuff
like that and play full-on defense I
don't even worry about the RAM because
most of the time the bots will not sit
next to the rim so the minions are gonna
be one speeding it and then it's gonna
take them a long time to even get to the
gate if you happen to be in a situation
where the RAM is at the gate then
repeatedly hit it with the cauldrons
that are located above the gate you can
do that a lot and they're very useful
they don't do a lot of damage but they
will eventually do a lot more damage if
they get to the inner gate which I'll
explain in a bit most of the time the
bots do get through the first phase but
they'll usually have like six lives
altogether or a very damaged Ram once
the attacking team gets through the
first gate a little bit of their RAM
health gets regen and gets replenished
but if you do a lot of damage it really
won't it really doesn't matter since you
put a very big dent in their health
because of the cauldron if they happen
to get to the commander don't worry the
bots can barely parry the commanders
move since most of them are unblockable
you could follow up with a punish when
they're hit just defend the commander
and any team buffs like damage or health
can be applied to the commander as well
so definitely use that
wisely in teamfights if the whole bot
team happens to rush you and there you
guys go like I said my defense game are
my fastest defense game on breach was
about eight to nine minutes we held them
off on the first area they bared they
didn't even get to the gate so that was
a very impressive of us but yeah let me
know what you guys think about this and
lastly now for the arcade effect you
just have to either complete all the
weekly quests or just one of the
chapters I'm not entirely sure I still
have not been able to play the weekly
quest which is the problem I was going
to get into that's really the only issue
is because at the time of making this
video the arcade weekly quest thing
aren't there if you go to the arcade
mode the actual arcade quests are there
at the bottom but the weekly quest thing
isn't there so I can't get the effects
so I can't actually tell you if it's
only you have to just do one of the
chapters or you have to go from the low
gear to the high gear completing all the
chapters in the and the weekly quest so
sorry I do not have a definitive God and
how to get that because it does not work
for me I don't know if it's that I don't
know if that's for a reason or if it's
down or if it's just me or something so
let me know in the comments below if
it's up for you guys or something like
that yeah guys it's gonna be the end of
the debate today hopefully you guys did
enjoy hopefully this did help you get
some of the loot the quickest I did get
a lot of loot from this like I said
still haven't gotten the effect they're
probably gonna hop on in a couple of
hours after this is live because I have
a few other things to do we're gonna hop
on and get that effect hopefully I can
get that for my mains and stuff like
that yeah I like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational side of foreigner that
being balance changes hero updates patch
notes leaks guides and all that type of
stuff see one if you want to be informed
with everything going on in for honor
I'm your guy for that and that guy's my
two most recent videos would be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out what that guy's hope if agrees to
Dave orts the video and peace out
[Music]